BANNBANNON ICTED TO
SURRENDER  IYO
STATE CHS IS
FUND-RAISING EFFORT TO BUILD A
DOING ANYTHING WRONG.NEW .ENIES
BANNON ONCE FACED L
S RELATED TOWALL SCHEME.IDENT T
PARDONEDIM.HE STARE
MIRROR
WAS CHARGED BY FEDERALPROSECUTO.
AS YOU REMEMBER, BANNO
T
IN AUGUST 2020.
RAS CHARGED HI
CROWD NDRAING DONORS I
Y BANNON AND IRATORS RAIS
T SECRETLYD
ABOUT $1 MILLION OF
RSONAL F
TRUMP PARDONED BANNON ON HISN O
PRFE CHAES
BECAUSE  CRG
TH ANDSE NEVERHE DIDT D , O TRL,
TH
-- IT MEANS HE
DOESN'T HAVE THIS ISSUE OF
KE WW WITH
MANHN DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
IN JUNE, CNN RORPT THAT LE IN NI
BNOTHIS?>> WELNON IS -STATE C
NOTHING MORE THAPOLITICAION OF R
TY LMYSELF, I NG T IT YEN TOTHED
JAKE. AR THE NEW CHARGE
ALWAYS FROM MR. BANNON.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> NOW, EY, GEORGE CONWAY, GAV
>> VERY DRAMATIC.
>>E ENJOYS THE DRAS
CA AS A LEGAL BATTER? AUL
BE PROBABLY A CARB TFEDERATHE F
REPRESENTATIONS TO T PUBLILE WEC
TRUE.E LINING THEIR OWN
POCKETL INDICTMENTUG
BY THEMP JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
WAS VERY EMPHATIC ABOU
AND ONE OF THE THINGOUT
COMMITRAUD IE 21st
ISTION
GOVERNMENT FOR WIRE FRAUD D
STATE.S  HAPIN ANY
RE.T DOWN THE S
THEY'RE GOHE STREET
A.TOOK THE SAMGEE
SAME PE BEG
ALLEGED TO HAVE BEEN D THE
SAME CASE.
>> BECSE Y
F BANNON'SNG AS SOMEBODYE  MONEN
SEEM TO BODEL .GAIN DOESN'T
>> SUSPECT STATE
PRVEEE  FEDERAL PROSECUTORS ABOT
GETTINOPLE WHO P
GUILTYIN THE STATE
CASE BEC
COULD BE USED TO THEIR HE FEDER
AND THEYULD GET SOME
LENICYN'T KNHAFACT,
IT WOULD MAKOF
SENSE.
BY MAGA FOLK LIKE CLETA MITCHERS
IN WHICHE HAVE SOME GGOPLE ARE L
TO BRING I B
WHAT DO YOU  IT'S PROFLY'S MAG
REBLHAVE TAKEN THERUMP HAS, BEEE
LE THERE.ARE TG UP -TTING UP TH
N OUT FOR
ATTH USING
P P
PER, THEY'RE GOING T
THROWN OUT AND THEY'RE GOING TOY
IT'S JUST VERY DISTURBING AND
THE FIRST HEARING  ON THE HEUDM
K T
NGLY JUST
LYHO DAYS.
ONLIP FIVE O
S,L RECAPTURE
OF RRE KILL TH
JA6th COMMITTEE.
ESSENTIAWSND
OTHEUMALLIES,  TE  THEthINVESTIY
HAVE, BECAUSE ONE WAY
K
IS GOIFINISHHE JANUARY
UP BY THE END OFMATTER WHAT.
MAYBE IF THE DEM
FUNDAMENTA RUN
OUCLOCK, BACOFS,
THESE EMAILS AND WE HA
THES
PPE AND
Y HIT POLLONE, AND ALL THESE PE
HAPPENED AT THWHA VERY GOOE
THANKS Th ABT
>> O OF THOUPS
WHOSE ER BEEIN
FOR SEDITIOUNSPIRA
Y,ERFAR RIGHT PARAMILI GROUP.
E ANTIEF  ALYS
LIORH KEEPERS.ADS  OF THE
REVEALS WHILE THERE ARE
MANY MEMBERSW ENEMTADERS,
E LECTED CIALS,EROYEES,HERELIGIU
BUSINESSN AMONG .AN TE ARRE
YES, EXTRM  MIME.
WE'RE JUST NOW WAKING UP T.YOU ?
THFAE MATTER IS,T'S
VIOLENCE, AND IT'S VERY  NUMBER
THINK THERE WERE 300 L
ENFORCEMENT OFFICEHOST.
ATDISTURBING.
ITAIESTIONS THAT
CONTINUE RAISE W GEORGE D
LAEMT N, IE CTT WE